le film que nous vous conseillons au
cinéma cette semaine au cinéma les yeux
d'elsa roux particulier c'est le film
edmond alors c'est un film de alexis
michalik qui est sorti récemment et que
certains d'entre vous ont peut-être
hésité à aller voir se disant ah je n'ai
pas vu la pièce de théâtre
j'aurais préféré voir la pièce avant etc
moi je vous dis que il faut voir les
deux de toute façon et puis que vous
allez voir quelque chose de complètement
différent alors évidemment le récit la
pièce de théâtre et le récit du film
sont les mêmes
petit retour en arrière la pièce de
théâtre 2010 cette aide mon grand grand
succès dans le théâtre privé 5 molière
enfin un véritable succès à paris et en
tournée en province
le film donc vient d'être réalisée est
sorti en adaptation à ce récit théâtral
le film est réalisé par l'auteur de la
pièce et il s'amuse vraiment dans ce
film a travaillé du cinéma évidemment le
thé au théâtre on est face à des acteurs
sur une scène et comme vous le savez le
film nous parle de la réalisation de la
conception du de la pièce cyrano de
bergerac par edmond rostand et bien là
dans le film il va nous faire faire ce
qu'il peut pas faire au théâtre c'est à
dire qu'il va nous faire entrer dans la
pièce montée sur scène être avec les
acteurs être avec les comédiens tournée
avec eux je vous préviens germi remis
donc à la fin de l'envoi je louche je
touche
nous allons modestement crayères
ensemble un château je vous conseille
véritablement vivement c'est une très
très belle histoire d'amour
c'est une très belle histoire d'amitié
c'est une très belle histoire de
création et c'est une très belle
réflexion du cinéma sur le théâtre
j'espère que vous viendrez le voir
nombreux ici au cinéma les yeux d'elsa
cette semaine la semaine prochaine et
partout ailleurs en france c'est un film
qui vont vraiment le détour